Melania Trump is planning to sue a
British newspaper for defamation yeah
yeah apparently the paper called her
happily married I about me
that's just a generic European accent I
don't know that was nothing specific no
I'm not Slovenian yeah no no oh hi Sam
it just goes for that goes for everyone
Donald Trump canceled a campaign rally
canceled a campaign rally scheduled for
Portland Oregon he canceled it yeah this
is devastating news for Portland's
conservative community Steve with at I
only got to Portland that ins a tie the
GOP has already started making a
strategy around the assumption that
Hillary Clinton will win the presidency
they're already making a strategy around
that idea yeah which may explain the
Republican Party's new slogan winter is
coming
[Applause]
fallout continues for Ryan Lochte that
guy is having a tough yeah we yeah yeah
yeah fallout continues for sponsors have
now dropped Olympic swimmer Ryan Lochte
for more on the bright side he just
signed a huge deal with Bob's urinal
cakes so minty yeah now in tangerine oh
oh tangerine they come in different
flavors your flavors
oh they're in flavors it's not like
you're done go you know I just met they
released sense you fellas know what I'm
talking yeah
you get back in there a little bit
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah remember those news from before you
were born
NASA in the news NASA is reporting that
it has finally heard from a lost space
probe after two years of silence
exciting yeah
not surprisingly the probe signal came
in at 2:00 a.m. and said you up
[Music]
maybe I'll come over this is weird it's
being reported that in the next I Oh s
update Siri will pronounce Barbra
Streisand's name correctly
yeah the news comes as a huge relief to
gay men over sixty this is a massive
change oh you're here
KFC ah everyone's now at caño what KFC
has released sunscreen that smells like
fried chicken people who've tried it say
it prevents you from getting cancer and
from having sex now we were talking
about that joke backstage I actually
think that would improve my right right
oh I would have sex with someone who
smelled like chicken yeah
yeah gender aside I wouldn't care that's
right
you smell that fried chicken and you
miss your ready to go going to town it's
why I've been thrown out of many camps
yeah you know true story uh an ex NFL
quarterback was arrested after being
found naked with meth and marijuana yeah
in other words he's back in the NFL
[Applause]
story out of North Korea North Korea has
reportedly released its own version of
Netflix called man bang all right all
right calm down everyone okay calm down
in the Korean language man bang means
anal sex
don't you feel immature
[Applause]
you